[Music]
if you were to lay your digestive tract
out in a straight line it would form a
tube spanning nearly 10 meters the last
1.5 meters of that are called the colon
or large intestine cells in this organs
lining constantly renew themselves but
the genes that moderate this process
occasionally go awry leading to the
excessive growth of new cells that
results in small growths or abnormal
clumps of cells called polyps the
majority of these polyps won't do any
harm but some can become cancerous when
their cells begin to grow and divide
rapidly projecting further into the
colon at that point they can transform
into colon cancer one of the most
prevalent and preventable forms of
cancer in the world that's a slow
process though growth times vary it
often takes around 10 years for a small
polyp to grow and develop into a
cancerous one we don't know exactly what
causes the majority of colon polyps and
colon cancers we do know in general that
colon cancer involves the activation of
what's called uncle genes in the polyp
and or the loss of tumor suppressor
genes that usually keep cancer cells in
check most cells have proto-oncogene x'
that help them grow when a
proto-oncogene mutates or there are too
many copies of it it can become a
permanently active aqua gene with cells
that grow out of control while we don't
yet know exactly what underlying factors
cause these changes experts suspect a
combination of both environmental and
inherited genetic factors in the worst
cases when cells within polyps divide
and spread unchecked they eventually
break through the lining of the colon
lymph and blood vessels carry those
cells all over the body and they can go
on to form tumors despite these
challenges there's a solution we've
become extremely good at detecting and
removing offending polyps before they
can cause cancer this happens through a
process called screening
and when we do it regularly we can
prevent many cases of colon cancer so
who's at risk most cases occur in people
aged 50 years or older
this group is considered at average risk
for colon cancer or colon polyps there's
also a higher risk group that includes
people with personal or family histories
of colon polyps or cancer and those who
suffer from inherited genetic syndromes
or inflammatory diseases like Crohn's
disease and ulcerative colitis so the
best age to initiate screening varies
from person to person if you have access
to healthcare it's best to consult a
doctor to find out when you should begin
screening can be done with various tests
colonoscopy involves a long thin
flexible tube that's fitted with a video
camera and light at the end and placed
internally to examine the colon for
polyps
if polyps are found a doctor can do a
polypectomy a procedure that removes
polyps from the colonic wall doctors can
also then test the polyp for cancerous
cells colonoscopy is the only test that
can be used to both find and remove
polyps there are however other useful
screening tests including imaging and
at-home tests that can allow patients to
examine their stool for small amounts of
blood
occasionally polyps are too large to be
removed during a colonoscopy in which
case the next step is surgery if blood
and imaging tests then reveal that
cancerous cells have spread outside the
colon then a special treatment like
chemotherapy may also be required to
stop the cancer from escalating we can
also take on certain habits to reduce
our likelihood of developing colon
cancer in the first place there's
evidence that maintaining a healthy
weight not smoking and being physically
active can help but most importantly
access to healthcare and regular
screenings at crucial times in life are
the best ways to prevent colon cancer
thank you to our community on patreon
for making this video possible and if
you're interested in more videos on the
topic of cancer check out this playlist
[Music]